à maurepas il sera candidat pour la
deuxième fois ismail havane bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes conseiller municipal
d'opposition de gauche vous êtes la tête
de liste de maurepas dynamique et
solidaire pour ce scrutin en 2014 on
rappelle que vous aviez totalisé 13 33%
des voix au second tour face au maire
élu grégory gary sied aussi à michel
chat pas pourquoi se lancer de nouveau
dans cette campagne des municipales
tout d'abord c'est un rendez vous que
nous avons donnée il ya six ans déjà je
ne sais pas si vous étés au moment
présent au moment de delà des résultats
qui étaient annoncés en micro en mairie
mais j'avais annoncé au mort pas un
rendez vous dans six ans nous y sommes
donc je suis candidat pour ce rendez
vous que nous avions données et parce
que aussi nous avons un certain nombre
d'idées et de valeurs apportées dans
cette commune qui ce qui a besoin je
pense deux changements de renouveau et
nous allons en parler tout à l'heure
avec le but peut-être de refaire
basculer mort pas à gauche la ville a
été un pendant 25 ans sous l'égide de
georges mougeot avant de basculer à
droite en 2014 un scrutin où la gauche
était partie divisée
à l'époque il y avait trois mêmes quatre
listes de gauche au premier tour
pas du nom également au deuxième tour
visiblement la la gauche ne va pas
repartir unis encore une fois pour cette
élection
alors je ne sais pas de quoi vous parlez
pour être honnête en 2014 puisque vous
parlez de 1000 2014 trois adjoints se
sont présentés à la municipal l'adjoint
de l'ancien dans de majorité georges
mougeot majorité à laquelle je
n'appartenais pas donc c'est à eux qu'il
faut poser la question
ce qui est sûr c'est que en 2014 ma
liste était content et l union de la
gauche pour le coup parce qu'il y avait
le parti communiste
europe ecologie les verts et le parti
socialiste donc l'union de la gauche
était fait à cette époque là en tout cas
pour pour notre part et aujourd'hui il
faut se tourner vers l'avenir ça c'est
le passé et parler des projets qui
intéressent les magasins et nous sommes
dans une logique complètement différente
que je souhaite exposer ce soir il y
avait quand même plusieurs listes de
tendance de gauche en 2014
alors cette fois-ci vous mènerez cette
liste avec à vos côtés martin fayolle
qui est fait partie de votre groupe
d'opposition c'est que vous avez une
sensibilité à gauche ismaila va nous est
d'ailleurs toujours adhérent au parti
socialiste même si vous
dites vous en êtes éloignée depuis 2010
est est ce que votre liste sera de
gauche et ce qu'elle rassemblera
diverses sensibilités politiques pour
être apprécié ma liste kate une liste
plutôt notre liste parce que nous sommes
plusieurs et une liste sans étiquette
moi je suis de gauche je lui ai toujours
dit tout le monde le sais j'étais
conseiller général socialiste son
cantonnement
quand on ne mord pas donc je suis de
gauche et je le reste on a ce sont mes
valeurs
néanmoins ce sont des valeurs qui sont
contemporaines et qui ne changent pas
dans le temps contrairement à des partis
qui sont l'incarnation dans le moment de
des valeurs auxquelles on adhère qui
peuvent être changeant comme vous pouvez
vous en douter mais aujourd'hui
effectivement nous sommes sur une liste
sans étiquette et que j'ai l'honneur de
conduire et j'ai le plaisir d'avoir des
hommes et des femmes qui ont une
intelligence d'esprit et l'ouverture
d'esprit pour pouvoir travailler sur un
projet commun quelquefois quelles que
soient les horizons et des parcours
qu'ils ont eue pour en terminer sur
votre question
la liste est composée d'hommes et de
femmes qui sont pour certains et
certaines de gauche qui viennent de
gauche qui sont encartés d'autres ne le
sont pas certains et certaines du centre
et d'autre ça a été aussi notre surprise
lorsqu'on a fait cet appel un large
rassemblement de droite mais ce qu'il
convient de dire c'est qu'ils partagent
tous cette idée d'avoir un projet commun
bâti autour de valeurs humanistes et
donc qu'est-ce que vous revendiquez un
soutien une investiture du parti
socialiste d'europe écologie les verts
pourquoi pas moi je ne revendique que
rien du tout la nature même d'une liste
sans étiquette si elle ne veut pas se
trahir
c'est de rester fidèle à ce large
rassemblement que nous avons demandé et
qui en train de se réaliser donc je ne
revendique que rien du tout après libre
à chacun de se retrouver dans les idées
que nous défendons et à ce titre
peut-être c'est le sens de votre
question nous sommes des hommes et des
femmes ouverts et nous vous invitons
lors de notre prochain veut député
européen europe ecologie les verts mais
s'il s'agissait d'une autre personnalité
encarté dans un parti ou non qui
adhèrent à nos idées nous l'aurions
aussi invités alors vous qui avez été
dans l'opposition comment ces six
dernières années qu'elle regarde
tu es sur la mandature du maire sortant
grégory caret astier je porte un regard
assez critique et je me dis aussi qu'il
y a un certain gâchis gâchis parce que
je comprends qu'en 2014 les mort passe
bien on espérait un renouveau puisque
nous avons un maire jeunes et donc du
coup ancré dans son dans son époque
force est de constater que aujourd'hui
d'urgence de notre époque c'est la
transition écologique
c'est un sujet transports complètement
oublié durant cette mandature et ça fera
partie d'un de vos quatre axes
prioritaires tout à fait alors c'était
un de nos piliers en 2014 et nous avons
créé ce large ressemble rassemblement
autour justement de l'idée de la
transition écologique et il ya cinq ans
donc c'est pas un effet de mode
on n'a pas fait pour les élections
municipales on a construit ce groupe il
ya cinq ans et donc du coup c'est notre
adn
et c'est pourquoi votre première
question pourquoi se présenter c'est
parce qu'il ya des choses à faire et en
urgence dans notre ville face au
bétonnage que vous avez certainement
constaté alors le bétonnage qui aussi
répond à un besoin en logements sociaux
qui sont environ 2 18% sur la commune de
maurepas on sait qu'il ya des impératifs
imposés par l'état d'atteindre ces 25 %
de logements sociaux comment justement
on apporte une réponse en se pliant aux
exigences de l'état et sans faire de
bétonisation il ya un projet d'éco
quartier qui est menée à maurepas ce
n'est pas une bonne réponse apportée on
a le droit d'être intelligent
effectivement les hommes et des femmes
ont besoin d'habitat pour se loger mais
pas de problème sur ce constat là
cependant il faut faire les choses de
manière intelligente et construite dans
le temps
aujourd'hui nous avons construit de
manière intense et rapide
à tel point que le bon sens a été oublié
le bon sens c'est quoi c'est toutes les
structures qui font force les écoles les
crèches les transports qui n'ont pas été
pensés et dimensionner suffisamment par
rapport à cet afflux de nouveaux
habitants qui vont arriver
ensuite et c'est un peu dommage sur ce
projet
que qui s'appelle écoquartier il aurait
pu être et dû être beaucoup plus
ambitieux pour d'un point de vue
écologique est réellement répondre à la
norme hqe yeux qu'il ne répond pas
aujourd'hui et nous allons le démontrer
lors de nos prochains prochain veux et
je trouve que c'est un gâchis et surtout
pour les morlaisiens des problèmes de
dimensionnement à venir au niveau des
structures locales alors trois autres
piliers pour votre candidature la
démocratie le pluralisme est là et la
justice sociale se fait alors en mousse
sur la démocratie c'est quelque chose de
ex de très important notre beau pays la
france pays de la liberté de la
démocratie a dans ses institutions
locales généré quand même quelques
effets qu'il faut corriger
rien n'interdit aujourd'hui d'avoir un
maire élu démocrate démocratiquement
mais qui se comporte comme un potentat
local et qui fait ce qu'il veut
le plus emblématique face à une
caricature qui n'a rien à voir avec le
débat aujourd'hui c'est balkany qui d'un
point de vue clientéliste alors qu'il a
été élu démocratiquement se permet de
faire ce qu'il veut dans sa ville alors
pour corriger cela ce que nous proposons
nous dans notre dans notre programme
c'est d'avoir une nouvelle gouvernance
locale qui associe beaucoup plus
finement les habitants au projet et à la
vie de la cité bible et participatif
mise en place par la majorité est la
suivante
ce n'est pas suffisant leur budget
participatif c'était aussi dans notre
projet en 2014 mais ce n'est pas
suffisant nous souhaitons remettre une
forme de comités de quartier renouveler
redistribuer qui n'existe pas
aujourd'hui à maurepas et qui est je
pense la base quand même d'une
démocratie et surtout que chaque projet
soit étudié dans le comité de quartier
et que les habitants et la primauté des
projets de construction et aussi la
parole et pourquoi pas la votation sur
les sujets d'orientation tels que ce n'a
pas été le cas pour la piscine par
exemple la piscine intercommunale avec
eux et long cours qui était l'un des
sujets phares sur cette fin de mandature
on le disait donc deux autres axes
justice sociale pluralisme c'est tout à
fait le pluralisme vous l'avez compris
notre liste sans étiquette pluralisme ça
veut dire que c'est ouvert
tout le monde pure pluralisme ce qui
montre d'ailleurs notre ouverture
d'esprit et si je pense que c'est dans
l'air du temps et c'est aussi notre adn
justice sociale parce qu'un certain
nombre d'habitants en particulier la
jeunesse à maurepas que nous avons
rencontrés au cours de nos nombreux
porte à porte se sentent complètement
délaissé perdu et ce sentiment est
renforcé encore une fois par le fait que
nous avons un maire jeunes et les jeunes
en particulier se reconnaissent pas dans
ce maire qui quelque part les amis de
côté en tout cas c'est ce qu' ils nous
disent et c'est que nous constatons
réellement et nous avons des
propositions à faire sur ce sujet
dernière chose qu'on arrive à la fin de
cet entretien à votre prochain rendez
vous de campagne
merci alors le prochain rendez vous de
campagne c'est lundi 27 janvier à 20
heures à la salle des coudrais routba
ceni où nous faisons ne veut annuel
depuis cinq ans et pour cette année avec
la particularité des élections nous
avons invité mounir satouri donc des
buts député europe ecologie les verts
député européen et nous profiterons de
cet événement pour donner plus de
détails sur la thématique de la
transition écologique et nous ferons des
mesures ou nous proposerons des mesures
qui sont assez innovante on mord pas
aimer omar badiane
merci smaïl havane tête de liste
maurepas dynamique et solidaire pour ce
scrutin face à vous je rappelle qu'il y
aura à le maire sortant divers droite
grégory deir estia également michel
chapa qui est aussi conseiller municipal
d'opposition et qui conduira une liste
oeuvre